va bene senti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo sono loculo
streep
ma voi avete presente tutti i cappelli
che mi metto durante i video anche loro
ci hanno dei sentimenti queste coach
hanno paura quindi immaginate per un
cappello che così tenero vedere un
horror cena vi sta facendo un appena
incredibile
ma sti cazzi che i ragazzi non fatti
veramente tanto ormai è tipo come fare
come lavarsi i denti la mattina è una
roba easy esista minchia vabbè loculo
sta giocando lo in un gioco fa lui aveva
fatto una caparra
c'è un amica ma che sta con gli amici a
quanta canon già finita
l'accordo ragazzi basta ste cagate
perché sono andiamo più avanti prego
fallo normalmente questa torta è una
roba
va beh vado avanti uguale tra l'altro
non ancora capito cosa dove siamo perché
ci siamo non va bene ok permesso sono fa
vj sono favi di james non segna ma che
cosa vuol fare il belle che diventa
diventa enorme quando ma vicino sto
stronzo ma perché siamo entrati qui
senza risorse stiamo morendo lentamente
perché voi stronzi non mandate qualcuno
clyde chi è chi è questo qui e clyde
c'erano delle persone intrappolate in
questo posto senza cibo parti c'è una
torta 15 senza cibo stocazzo a me di qua
non si gioca bowling in questo posto è
vietato sapete chi è che ha lanciato la
che cos'è un casco spero tutti sia
salvato perché il casco non è messo
molto bene ho visto i maleducati cos'è
quella luce blu che vedo che cazzo è
permesso ho parcheggiato male la smart
credo sia un altro casco ma basta vengo
in panne lungo video preso così mica sti
cosi che spunta mi fanno una cagata
pazzesca c'è scritto che devo andare al
mercato a comprare le carote e poi c'è
scritto state lontani da lui sempre
clyde da lui dalla pianta lontana pianta
mi chiamavano mica capito e lo stacco la
madonna che è passato quindi una tipa
col ciclo
l'evento ci ho capito che siamo sulle
vendute micari pressione un'altra volta
se non è chiaro ancora piante un
telefono che leggermente sporco di
maestro 6 vaso salvate cimo arrivate di
fama ordinato una pizza qualcosa ci sarà
un express a livello spaziale da voi che
fa eco tipo questo con questa una
parabola ma prende sky state cucinando
del maiale vivo state lottando la cena
di natale di vostra nonna fate capire il
senso di questo brutto incredibile c'è
un sovraccarico a cazzo poi cosa è
successo
gesù gesù sei tu non fai niente ragazzi
ho visto di pregio sua release all
action va bene così è una pianta ed è
malvagia caso io vorrei ancora capito
darci il tuo markose cazzo è caduto è
caduto un barile ma se sia capisce il
mio ruolo in tutto questo sarebbe anche
se è passato un telefono io ho io non ho
toccato un cazzo anche perchè poi è
colpa mia non c'era la parabola era la
finestra sbagliata perché la pena royal
a troy e tara l'ho detto
esce su un tizio da soffitto ma dettagli
mi fate capire che cosa c'entra notizie
i nudi in questo posto pieno di sangue
per favore via ma proprio veloci via
devo correre come una lettera messo io
entro qua dentro che sta macchinetta ce
l'hai mikado se metto due euro no mica
gas isgrò sismica si sto amando da
morire ma spiegami il senso poi lavarti
le mani gemiti pulito si dichiari
talmente pulito amici specchio e sento
dei rumori non brutti di più c'è una
roba indecente
la freccia indica dico io vado di quasi
giuro che se cadi madonna manrovescio
che ti arriva ma chiesta voce che
sentono i barili
i barili che non ci fa un passaggio ri
di stronzi tagliatevi delle rose guarda
amico non è ancora san valentino
non ho capito che cosa sta succedendo ma
va bene così stanno aggredendo e
stuprando una pianta nicolai gara sia
fabbriche che si fa quasi a bobby dove
vai zio ndo vai se mi spunti per caso di
qua e ti lancio la smart inseguitori
hanno ucciso a un suk e che è un nome
perché c'è della musica anni 80 qua
dietro via veloci di qua perché non
voglio saperlo ancora continua
tranquillamente essere stuprata nonché
disturbiamo c'è una tazzina di te delle
pringles ma cove delle frigo ho preso
una vera ragazza e non ho assolutamente
paura di usarlo dio mi difendo con le
pere perché ho la mia sa di quali carico
a perfetto vaio ma adesso ci dorme
qualcuno contento perché sono mi prenoto
io c'era un orsetto sul soffitto
i dettagli sono costati sia bobby e buon
vento ti porta in questo posto bello a
sego io me ne vado fottutamente via non
voglio vedere che cazzo se su quel
monitor nome ne frega niente via via via
via via via via ma veloci dalla tua
madre è si può finire questo gioco è la
madonna che in your song ansia addosso
chi non ha veramente ragazzina così
impensabile via dite ciao
che cosa cazzo cela sopra voglio uscire
ufficialmente da questi tutta da questa
[ __ ] non ho mai visto una mano così
grande puoi farti le pippe così grandi
ma non toccarmi in un game boy maqoma
come ma chi è che a giocarne avevano a
corto di parole ragazzi quello del pube
we were you
noi ti vestiamo firmato zara kiss nodi
su disco disarmava benissimo andava
benissimo che per quanto come ci entrò
subito bellissimo non mi piace dal
scritta di caschi li lasciamo là sopra
che
raga aperto aperto aperto via via via
via via via via nord mi sfruttavano casa
urlo la mamma piacere farisei non mi
interessa sapere con chi ha staccato con
la mano non voglio sempre cos'è il
cinema questo a sardi e non mi avete
marco ha lasciato un euro per comprare
la coca cola marte il martello prendi il
martello mint uccidi uccidi chiunque
voglia ucciderti del jack daniel's per
questo gioco ci stessimo ha visto a
prenderla fissa prendi la prendi la
pistola nave veloce cazzo cei seria via
via viano la premia pista non apre non
la prendo mi interessa più
cori ma sa che corri corri applicarli fa
qualcosa non mi sto guardando manco
indietro non so cosa c'è dito nemmeno mi
interessa via via via vi abbiano ovunque
ho vinto ho vinto o perso vinto per
welcome to nicolae stan a [ __ ] pò vinto
o perso non mi interessa basta che me ne
vado di qua che non mi sta piacendo
questo gioco brutto dovrò passare l'ha
vista giocare a pac man
ma cosa no non può essere la missione
speciale clyde stato trovata
intrappolata dentro uno dei livelli 256
nome la farai un cazzo basta che torna a
casa o sul no
che fine ha fatto o su chi ha o su che
che fine hai fatto a o su che essi
diventato una macchinetta per la coca
cola o su che senz'altro è stato
brutalmente mutilato è trasformato in
una vending machine una macchina che
vende coca cola chaser cos'è il patto a
da un suk è diventato un libro cesar
commander chase è stato circondato da
libri e da idee ed è stato ucciso dalla
creo di libri line
pinky a o sud e chase erano la missione
six sono morti con onore di end e la
morale di tutto questo è che tutti
quanti noi compreso how su che
diventeremo delle macchinette per la
coca cola perfetto ragazzi concluso qui
l'episodio è stato il gioco horror più
figo della storia ma tutto per merito di
house su che perché se non sarebbe mai
stato così e detto questo ragazzi
concluso qui episodio è stato tragico a
dir poco veramente spero che tutti
lascerete un mi piace per how su che è
per clyde che erano i miei preferiti ma
adesso ho suk e un pochettino di più
perché c'è stato è diventato una
macchinetta per vendere non c'è e coca
cola
ma che cazzo c'è un po di meritocrazia
come se il video è piaciuto al santo
momento mi piace anche a passare in
facebook e condivido trovate la
descrizione signoris i destinatari ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazza